Many botnets use DNS for C&C.
A key advantage is that DNS is used
whenever a machine on the internet
needs to talk to another machine,
because DNS stores the mapping
between domain name and IP address.
That is DNS is always
allowed in a network.
And therefore, using DNS for
C&C won't stand out easily.
In this example here,
the Botmaster releases malware and
in the malware, the domain name
of the C&C servers are coded.
Have the malware spreads,
then the question is, how do the bots
communicate back to the Botmaster?
In other words, how do they
perform C&C with the C&C server?
To perform C&C, each bot is instructed
to communicate to the C&C server.
As we said, the C&C server is
identified by the domain name.
So the first thing the bot will
do is ask the DNS server, hey,
what's the IP address for hacker.com?
And the DNS server will tell the bot,
here is the IP address.
And then, the bots would actually
communicate to the C&C server.
And that's how Botnet C&C
works through DNS.
The kind of DNS service providers
preferred by the bot masses
are the dynamic DNS providers,
because they allow the frequent changes
of the mapping between domain name and
IP address.
That is the Botmaster can
change to use another machine.
User 10.0.0.1 for example,
you can change it to 10.0.6.2 for
example.
It's a C&C server for the same botnet,
and all he needs to do is log into
the dynamic DNS provider and
change the map ping, so
that now hackers.com points
to the new IP address.
If we can detect that hackers.com
is a useful botnet C&C,
then we can detect that any machine
that connects to it is a bot.
But the question is, how do we know
that hackers.com is useful botnet C&C?
It turns out that the way
that bots look up a domain
would suggest that this domain is
most likely used for botnet C&C.
That is, the way that bots look up
a domain would be different from
a machine that looks up a web server
because of legitimate use activities.
Such as, when a user is
looking up a news website.
For example, if a domain such as
hackers.com is being looked up
by hundreds of thousands of
machines all over the internet and
yet this domain is
unknown to Google Search.
This is an anomaly.
Therefore, we can use anomaly detection
at the Dynamic DNS provider to examine
queries to DNS domains in order
to identify Botnet C&C domains.
Once we identify that
hackers.com is used for
Botnet C&C, there are a number
of responses available.
One option is for a Dynamic DNS provider
to send a mapping of hackers.com
to the IP address of a sinkhole.
That is, instead of giving the IP
address of the C&C machine to the bots,
the dynamic DNS provider would give the
IP address of the sinkhole to the bots.
Therefore, instead of connecting
to the actual C&C server,
all the bots will be connecting
to a sinkhole machine.
As a result, the Botmaster will
not be able to command his bots.
Because when he logs to the C&C
server and looks through the logs,
he will not be able to find the bots.
Because all the bots are instead,
communicating with the sinkhole machine.
With the sinkhole, in addition to
disabling the botnet operations,
security researchers can
learn where the bots are.
For example, by looking at each
connection from the bot to the sinkhole,
security researchers would know
the IP address of each bot,
therefore it would know where
the bots are throughout the Internet.